she was originally introduced as the
daughter of Batman and Catwoman and made
her way back from being dead not once
but twice let's take a look at all the
incarnations of the Huntress like a lot
of the most confusing pieces of the DC
Universe the Huntress has her roots in
earth too and her case though it's not
just a simple story of crossing
dimensions more than anyone else she
shows how an attempt to solve a
storytelling problem that didn't really
matter gave DC the chance to take their
characters in some very unexpected
directions it starts in the 1960s when
DC decided they needed to explain why
there were new characters with the same
names as a few were the old ones the
extremely simple solution was the dive
headfirst into the idea of parallel
worlds in the pages of flash a parallel
world called Earth 2 was created as a
home for all of the original versions of
the DC superheroes of course the idea of
earth 2 also created a few new problems
like Al some of the earth 2 heroes
existed as fictional comic book
characters on earth one Barry Allen for
example chose to name himself the flash
because he'd read the same comics about
the original flash Jay Garrick that were
published in the real world apparently
nobody ever read the ones about how
Batman and Superman were really Bruce
Wayne and Clark Kent one of the most
interesting things about earth 2 was
that DC now had versions of its most
popular characters that could change in
ways the ones in the main stories never
could earth to Superman was happily
married to Lois Lane while his earth 1
counterparts was still refusing to
settle down as he waged his never-ending
battle against evil the same went for
the Batman family
Dick Grayson grew up keeping his
identity as Robin into adulthood and
Bruce Wayne retired from crime-fighting
and married Selina Kyle
better known as Catwoman earth twos
Batman and Catwoman would even die after
their retirements prompting an elderly
Joker to go on a rampage after being
denied a final clash with his
arch-nemesis long before that however
Bruce and selina had a child together
her name was Hellena Wayne and as you
might expect it wasn't long before she
joined the family business as a crime
fighter she took the name Huntress and
wore costume that combined Batman's
pointy-eared look with cat woman's
traditional purple what might be
surprising though is that she wasn't the
kind of prominent character you'd expect
Batman and Catwoman daughter to become
while she started a few stories and
fought crime alongside the grown up
Robin as the new
dynamic duo Elena Wayans most prominent
appearances came when she took an
interdimensional vacation to earth one
to spend some time with that world's
version of her dad of course meeting up
with the alternate reality daughter you
fathered with the supervillain is always
going to be a little weird but you know
it's the DC Universe you get used to
stuff like that by the mid-80s DC's
multiverse had expanded well beyond
Earth to into a whole roster of
alternate worlds built around different
ideas one where the Nazis won World War
two when where Kennedy was never
assassinated a what one where all of us
are evil been there it sucks in 1985
they tried to clean it all up with a 12
issue events called crisis on Infinite
Earths the ads for the series claim that
worlds will live worlds will die and the
DC Universe will never be the same
and while comic books have often
featured some tag lines that went way
over the top this one actually lived up
to it the main effect of the story was
that the multiverse of parallel worlds
was obliterated and streamlined into a
single unified timeline as a result
there was no more earth to Batman
because there was no more earth to to be
the Batman up if earth - didn't exist
then neither did Helene at Wayne it's
worth noting that Huntress was one of
the few characters to survive the
initial destruction of her home to
mention finding herself stranded
alongside her Earth's Robin on a strange
world with no record of her existence
with nothing left for her in the
universe she joined Robin on a final
fatal mission the final indignity the
story specifically states that her body
and Robins were never recovered after
their deaths here's the thing about
superhero comics nothing ever really
goes away
especially when it's tied to a character
as prominent as Batman with that in mind
it's no surprise that DC brought back
the Huntress only a few years after
crisis what is surprising is that they
completely reinvented the character in
almost every aspect aside from her
costume and her first name and even the
costume underwent some radical changes
before too long
instead of being Batman's daughter the
post-crisis Huntress was something a
little closer to being DC's take on the
Punisher Helena Bertinelli was the
youngest member of one of Gotham C's
most prominent mobster families in the
years before Batman arrived and
organized crime was mostly replaced by
evil clowns and mad scientist's with ice
guns when she was only eight years old
Alana's entire family was murdered in
front of her by a hitman who left
live is the only survivor milena was
taken in by her family and Sicily who
offered the trainer so that she could
get a revenge something that she took to
very well when she returned to Gotham
however she saw Batman in action and
realized that if she really wanted to
strike terror in the hearts of the
mobsters who had targeted her family she
should follow in his footsteps as a
vigilante with that she took the
identity of the Huntress although that
wasn't her only calling while she was
wealthy enough to live off her family's
ill-gotten gains she actually kept a day
job as a schoolteacher something that
would have more prominence and other
versions of the character you don't
really get to be a vigilante in Gotham
City without attracting some attention
from be vigilante in Gotham City
sure enough the new Huntress soon
encountered Batman the big sticking
point between the two characters comes
from the way they deal with their
enemies most versions of Batman famously
have a code against killing the Huntress
on the other hand has no problem at all
sending her opponents off to their final
reward still Batman didn't set out to
take the Huntress down after all if
there's one person who understands the
intense trauma of watching your family
get gunned down in front of you and the
anger that can lead you to put on a
costume and wage work and stalked
criminals by night it's that guy still
he didn't approve of her methods but the
solution he came up with for this
particular problem wasn't the one that
anyone expected he let her join the
Justice League
Batman's hope was that membership in the
JLA surrounded by Paragons of virtue
like Superman and Wonder Woman would be
a good influence on the Huntress and
show her a different way of fighting
crime it did not work when Batman found
her getting ready to execute a helpless
super villain at the climax of one of
the league's biggest crises he booted
her out of the league in disappointment
Hellena Bertinelli's relationship with
the rest of the Batman family is a
little complicated we've already been
through her rocky interactions with the
Dark Knight himself but his sidekicks
tend to have a very different
perspective on Huntress Tim Drake for
instance had the sort of relationship
you'd expect from a super smart teenage
overachiever and a world-weary teacher
her relationship with Dick Grayson
better known as Nightwing is a little
more mature when he first encountered
the Huntress they had immediate
chemistry and they quickly found
themselves in a team-up with benefits an
actual relationship didn't blossom out
of that encounter though partly because
of the time that Huntress
accidentally shot Batman with a crossbow
in front of Nightwing
there are definitely exceptions but
using medieval weaponry on someone's
beloved father figure is going to be a
deal breaker
even more than Batman himself Hellena
Bertinelli's most complicated
relationship within the Dark Knight's
group of assorted sidekicks was with
Barbara Gordon and before you start
wondering it actually had very little to
do with Barbara's on-again off-again
relationship with Dick Grayson instead
the biggest source of conflict came from
what was essentially the super heroic
equivalent of copyright infringement
it happened in no-man's land a year-long
crossover event where a devastating
earthquake left Gotham City broken and
abandoned by the government after
unsuccessfully campaigning to save the
city Bruce Wayne was left dejected and
depressed and even contemplated
abandoning the city himself while
supervillains carved Gotham into their
own little fury road territories while
Batman was gone a mysterious new bat
person appear who eventually turned out
to be the Huntress using Batman's
identity and iconography to give hope to
the remaining citizens when Batman
returned he gave her his approval to
continue acting as the air SATs Batgirl
which didn't sit well with Barbara Babs
had been forced to give up on being
Batgirl after being paralyzed by the
Joker and was infuriated by the idea of
Batman giving away something that she
still thought of as a big part of her
identity without even telling her who
was under the mask eventually around the
same time that she was fired from the
JLA Huntress gave up the Batgirl
identity voluntarily but no man's land
also provided her with a measure of
redemption for what Batman had seen as
her failings when the Joker launched the
horrifying attempt to murder every baby
born in Gotham during the no man's land
year Huntress made a heroic last stand
to protect the kids she wound up
fighting a small army of Joker Impostors
and was shot by the real Joker multiple
times in the process perhaps
surprisingly she survived the experience
after the injuries she suffered in no
man's land
Hellena Bertinelli made a full recovery
man so did her relationship with Barbara
Gordon for a while as Oracle Barbara
founded a team of her own called birds
of prey coordinated missions with other
super heroines as her operatives having
felt aimless four years after her
experiences in no man's land the
Huntress joined up alongside Oracle and
Black Canary
the camaraderie of the team seemed to be
doing a lot of good for Helena allowing
her to move past the anger and desire
for revenge that had driven her since
she was a child
unfortunately it was short-lived after a
few adventures with the birds she
realized that Oracle had been sending
her on missions designed to teach her
lessons and push her towards
self-improvement
treating her the same way a teacher
might handle a problem student
infuriated at being manipulated by yet
another member of the Batman family who
seemed to want to mold her into what
they wanted her to be she ditched the
team and left in 2002 the WB launched a
birds-of-prey TV show loosely and that's
the key word here based on the comic of
the same name are you I'm the Huntress
and you're the prey the show focused on
two heroines the first was Barbara
Gordon played by dina meyer who had been
Batgirl until she was shot by the Joker
and had reinvented herself as Oracle the
second as though things weren't
complicated enough already was Helene a
Kyle played by Ashley Scott's like the
original earth to Huntress
he was the daughter of Batman and
Catwoman heavily implied to be the
version seen on the big screen in Batman
Returns
unlike Hellena Wayne however this
version never knew her father with
Catwoman keeping her birthday secret
from Batman still after Batman's
apparent - she took the identity of the
Huntress and carried on his legacy
alongside Barbara protecting a younger
version of Black Canary Dinah Lance the
show only lasted a single 13 episodes
season before it was canceled it did
have some interesting ideas however
including casting a version of Harley
Quinn as the main villain of the series
marking one of the first time she'd
stepped out of the Joker's shadow
very pleased it's Harley Harley Quinn
and quite soon this city but what's left
of it will be mine it wasn't entirely
forgotten either seventeen years after
the last episode aired and only weeks
before the Huntress made it to the big
screen in the birds of prey movie Ashley
Scott returned to the role for a cameo
in CW's crisis on Infinite Earths
crossover check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superheroes
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]